so stellen sich partytouristen mallorca
vor
und so wünscht sich der stadtrat von
palma das neue image mallorca eine insel
mit stil neue gesetze sollen dabei
helfen
60 polizisten sind dafür verstärkt auf
streife die regeln gelten seit diesem
sommer am party strand von el arenal
es drohen strafen von bis zu 600 euro
am strand ist es verboten aus
glasflaschen zu trinken
bitte unterlassen sie dass viele
touristen denken weil sie im ausland
sind können sie machen was sie wollen
so läuft das aber nicht schließlich ist
der strand für alle da nicht nur für die
touristen
der berüchtigte sangria eimer am
ballermann strand ist jetzt vermuten
das bade outfit soll nicht mehr in den
seitenstraßen von el arenal getragen
werden einschränkungen die die
atmosphäre am ballermann verändern
sollen
es ist was anderes markt doch schon von
der atmosphäre hier am strand vor allem
aber der stimmung allgemein so viel
saufen ist halt ballermann ich war ich
mache nicht aber soll die leute lassen
ist nichts schlimmes
das ist schon die richtige richtung
einschlagen
die party urlauber sind nicht die
wichtigste einnahmequelle für die
tourismusbranche mallorcas sie sorgen
aber für das modell mit die touristen
geben vor ort deutlich weniger aus das
reiseziel palma ist in die jahre
gekommen
wir haben lange hin und her überlegt wie
wir diesen urlaubsort neu positionieren
können damit er an qualität gewinnt mit
besseren liegen zum dreifachen preis hat
die modernisierung nicht weit vom
berühmten ballermann 6 schon begonnen
die stimmung tagsüber ist hier schon
deutlich ruhiger geworden
in den straßen von el arenal wird abends
aber weiter ausgelassen gefeiert
hier spielen die neuen gesetze für die
touristen kaum eine rolle rund vier
millionen deutsche urlauber kommen jedes
jahr auf die insel
an der playa de palma seien es aber
schon weniger geworden beobachten sie
sollen arbeiter dieses jahr also hier
kamerun laufen hier sind mehr ältere
leute als junge leute und auch die
ganzen boden mit polizei und hin und her
das ist eigentlich lächerlich also von
daher ist der ballermann nicht mehr das
was es mal war aber nur einmal im jahr
in den clubs bekommen die party urlauber
weiter alles geboten was zum ballermann
urlaub dazu gehört schlagerstar peter
wackel sorgt schon seit 15 jahren
verstimmung er glaubt nicht dass
luxustourismus an der playa de palma
eine chance hat kumpels von mir wollen
ja auch in gstaad auf einmal hat das
wlan flatscreens sauberes neues bad und
kostet aber noch ausgleichen würden
vorher so von luxus merke ich hier noch
gar nicht und fallen bitte wer baut sich
den finger entweder ist in deutschland
millionär dann ist er ja auch millionär
aber hier kommen nicht die schönen und
reichen dafür ist sie auf meiner ganz
toll aufgeteilt also pleite palm hat ist
ja ein party strand genau wie die für
die engländer
magaluf ist dafür haben wir aber dann
port adriano porto portals wo dann
wirklich auch die schönen und reichen
flanieren die schönen und reichen
treffen sich im moment noch abseits des
ballermann zum beispiel im beachclub in
palma internationales publikum
entspannte stimmung und kein gedränge am
strand genauso ein bild soll beim wort
new yorker im kopf entstehen wünschten
sich die behörden um das zu erreichen
sollen am hafen neue feinschmecker
restaurants eröffnen und mehrere hotels
sollen auf vier und fünf sterne
hochgerüstet werden in fünf bis sechs
jahren sollen mallorca sich verändert
haben
für die rund zehn millionen besucher die
jedes jahr kommen will sich die insel
von ihrer stilvollsten seite zeigen